in a farm in wyoming the cheneys came to
accept defeat liz cheney the latest to
most high-profile republican victim of
donald trump she has lost her seat but
she says the fight against him has only
just started this primary election is
over
but now the real work begins i have said
since january 6th that i will do
whatever it takes to ensure donald trump
is never again anywhere near the oval
office and i mean it
liz cheney's been an implacable opponent
of donald trump and voted to impeach him
and has now paid the price her opponent
in this conservative rural state
repeated trump's lie the election he
lost was rigged in turn he came here to
campaign against liz cheney and
predicted this outcome
and it's why in two months from now the
people of wyoming are going to tell her
liz you're fired get out of here get out
of here
but cheney's defiance in defeat is
increasing speculation she might take
him on herself
this jenny has stopped short of saying
she'll run for president in 2024 against
donald trump but she's using this defeat
to renew her fight against him and her
teams say she believes it could make her
stronger
[Music]
the wyoming election has again
underlined the strength of the trump
faction among republicans his supporters
want him to announce his running soon
behind the wheel of his customized 71
pontiac bob ferguson says it's just a
matter of time all the stuff that's
happened since he's been out of office
has probably convinced him more and more
that he he wants to be president again
and wants to to redeem what
what's been done against him cheney's
defeat shows the power of trump even
from the sidelines and the republican
party's divisions as potential battle
lines start to be drawn ahead of the
2024 election
dominic waghorn sky news wyoming
oh well after hearing the results donald
trump took to his truth social app
congratulating the winner and guess what
hitting out at liz cheney
uh this is a wonderful result for
america he says and a complete rebuke
for the unselect committee of political
hacks and thugs
liz cheney should be ashamed of herself
the way she acted and her spiteful
sanctimonious actions words and actions
towards others
now she can finally disappear into the
depths of political oblivion where i am
sure she will be much happier than she
is right now thank you wyoming
i think i think donald trump may well be
off liz cheney's christmas card list